i've been telling you for about a year
now that we can expect over the 18 to 24
following months now the sort of
following six to 12 months
for isis to lose major territory in the
middle east as well as
many of their key people making the more
important question
how do you stop the impact of their
radicalization
ideology across the west this is
happening
isis has lost major territory in syria
and in iraq
we now have early initial reports from
syrian state television that say that
the leader of isis
abu bakr al-baghdadi was killed in an
airstrike in
raqqa syria on saturday night and if
you've been following
a sort of movement of isis raqqa has
been
a sort of nerve center for isis a
headquarters of sorts for their
activities
which also include sex trafficking as
well as attacks in
syria iraq elsewhere isis controls all
aspects of life in raqqa they've taken
over the government they control the
schools
they've set up courts and police to
enforce sharia law
some of their worst displays have taken
place there
like public executions public displays
of bodies
and false claims of al-baghdadi's death
have been reported reported before pat
so we'll have to see what ultimately
comes of this there are
skeptical independent experts but at the
same time
we're seeing more and more unified
reporting about this killing so
this is important in terms of
destabilizing
isis organizationally in the first place
but we have to remember
that if an individual in france is
radicalized by the ideology of isis
the killing of this particular person if
true
is not going to change the ability of
that individual in france to become
radicalized yeah but it might take some
time for our own us government to
confirm the fact that baghdadi was
killed if he in fact was
but that's pretty standard mohammed
emwazi who is colloquially known as
jihadi john who was featured in those
videos of beheadings of james foley and
others
he was killed in an airstrike in
november of 2015 but the us government
didn't confirm that until the following
month
uh that long it took okay yeah so we may
have some time to wait but the sort of
key aspect here is that defeating isis
isn't going to happen through just
bombing their physical territory in the
middle east and killing leaders
and this is why it's so complex because
isis and jihadism
and those who sympathize exist globally
throughout
the world throughout the muslim world
and that can include
majority muslim countries it can include
particular communities enclaves in
western countries as well
and as we see each time we have one of
these attacks in the uk
france belgium the u.s jihadists of this
flavor are decentralized and worldwide
are fulfilling what they see as their
mission whether they have direct
connections to institutions or
individuals in syria and iraq
led by al-baghdadi or not the real
objective
has to be fighting fighting radical
islamist ideology and
many people refer to these suicide
attacks that we've been seeing
as mindless acts or mindless killings
but they aren't really mindless they're
intentional planned acts
that are carried out with the purpose of
killing those who are going against
whatever the believed
doctrine is of these individuals and
this is often by people who have been
proven to be
educated and i guess you could say
otherwise mentally sound
the whole mental illness thing is
complex because on the one hand
how mentally sound can you be if you're
willing to kill yourself and others on
the basis that
god likes it and you'll end up in heaven
with 72
virgins but the truth is that saying all
of these perpetrators are merely insane
is really an insult to people who deal
with mental illness
overwhelmingly people who are quote
mentally ill are not violent periods so
yes there may be mental illness involved
in some cases
but there is always more than that and
it's this radicalization
it's this reading or false reading or
accurate but perverted reading call it
what you want
plausible reading of the scripture that
they believe
calls for this type of violence so the
problem isn't
sort of fundamentalism it's kind of a
classic example
if you think of the religion jainism
jainists are vegetarians whose entire
lives revolve around
not harming other living things
extremism
in a chain is basically people
staring at the ground when they walk so
they don't step on bugs or kill bacteria
or drinking water through cheese cloth
so you don't accidentally drink up or
eat a bug right that's
extremism and jainism extremism per se
doesn't directly lead to what we're
seeing through these readings of the
hadith and the quran
so that's where the focus i think needs
to be no it really is two parts one part
of that of course is if it's a
fundamentalist approach and then the
other part is the ideology itself yes
and perhaps the problem is more severe
when it comes to islam because there
hasn't
been that enlightenment that
christianity has had and of course the
key prophet in christianity was seen as
this peaceful hippie type guy where
you can't really say the same thing when
it comes to islam yes although there's
been no shortage of people doing
violence
uh under under christianity as well in
the u.s as we talk about worldwide
most terror is conducted committed by
muslims in the united states by and
large it is committed by white
christians even if you call them
so-called casual christians so killing
radicals in raqqa is not going to solve
the problem we have to commend and
empower those within the muslim
community
whose mission it is to moderate and
modernize the religion as well as
ex-muslims whose mission it is
to support and protect other ex-muslims
and the left has this horrible habit
of demonizing inside reformers i don't
have to mention their names you probably
know who some of them are
because they see jihad as a political
problem not as a religious one
and they see attempts to reform and
foster defection
as a sort of attack on the muslim
community and you really have to
separate the two so encourage muslim
communities to be more willing to
communicate
with law enforcement encourage moderate
interpretations of the quran and the
hadiths
but we're never going to get anywhere
unless we name
the particular flavor of islamist
ideology that needs to be targeted
that's not islamophobia it is actually
distinguishing
radicals from reasonable muslims and i
think that saying extremist islam
doesn't exist is a real problem i think
saying moderate islam doesn't exist
is also a problem because whatever you
can point to
in the scriptures you see it in
christianity there is huge
violence in the bible but you have
moderate christians just
as you have radical christians who are
willing to commit terror under that
umbrella so
we'll see if this is ultimately
confirmed big news if it
is but not a panacea no doubt about it